across the Marvel Cinematic Universe as
many movies countless epic fights have
unfolded we've seen incredible showdowns
between the likes of Thor and Hulk Hulk
in the Hulkbuster Captain America and
Red Skull and so many more
however for as many cool fight scenes as
there are across the MCU filmography
it's pretty obvious that some conflicts
in the MCU are inherently more
captivating than their peers these are
the greatest fight scenes in the MCU
Captain America vs Iron Man this fight
in Captain America Civil War is the
payoff to over half a decade's worth of
tension building between the MC use two
biggest heroes across both Avengers
movies we'd see these fan favorite
characters butt heads while their solo
movies push them even farther into
different perspectives that kind of
friction could only be resolved in one
way and audiences were waiting for it
the scene led us revel in seen our
favorite hero beat the snot out of the
other guy and gave us an MCU fight with
some actual emotional stakes another
excellent aspect of the fight is how
close it is to its comic book
counterpart in terms of general tone and
shot composure
the battle pays tribute to its source
material without being limited by it and
raises the MCU cinematography standards
all inside a few short sweet minutes the
Hydra fortress assault courtesy of
Avengers age of Ultron this fight scene
from the moment it begins is an absolute
joy not only does it display each of the
core Avengers and all their glory but it
does so through the use of one
continuous shot that strings together
the different Avengers in a sweeping
interconnected style every avenger gets
their time to shine as icing on the cake
the opening scene caps off with a
beautiful group shot of all the Avengers
leaping into battle as a combined unit
and it's at that moment you're reminded
why Marvel's interconnected universe was
worth all the effort
[Music]
iron man's assault on terrorism it's one
of Iron Man's first major fight scenes
featuring Tony Stark taking down
terrorists in the Middle East right
after he's developed his mark three Iron
Man suit and it's an instantly classic
collection of cool moments this single
scene was a milestone for superhero
cinematography displaying a whole new
breed of superhero action that fans at
the time didn't even know was possible
Iron Man and war machine versus hammer
drones but wait Iron Man's battles got
even cooler when Iron Man 2 came along
no other fight scene in the MCU s
history has filled its frames with
cherry blossom petals swirling around
two guys in robot suits and that can
only be considered a huge missed
opportunity given how cool it looked in
this scene more importantly this scene
is one of the only times we get to see
Rhodey use his war machine armor to its
fullest potential while he and Iron Man
get a cool team-up throwback scene in
age of Ultron nothing quite compares to
their first go-around at the end of Iron
Man 2 I think you should lead with that
next time the guardians of the galaxy
versus Ronan towards the end of
guardians of the galaxy Ronan the
accuser saddles up to declare his
triumph over the Nova Corps in the
Guardians until star-lord interrupts him
and challenges him to a fight to the
death by dance-off these words what
comes after however might be even better
the guardians United join forces in the
most unaccountable Dean session in the
history of cinema literally vaporizing
Ronan with his own infinity stone if
only all dance-offs ended this way the
tarmac throwdown
so far not one other movie in the
massive multi franchise saga can claim
to have a scene with as much raw literal
super heroism as this one from Civil War
given that there are no fewer than 12
Marvel superheroes throwing down at the
same time
[Music]
Civil War star Maxine is a cacophony of
comic-book noise crammed into frames
that are barely big enough to hold all
the action for the sheer scope of the
fight alone
this scene easily earns its lot on this
list Captain America and Bucky z-- final
fight there's not a single fight in the
MC US history that's quite as painful to
watch as the one between Bucky and cap
at the end of Captain America the Winter
Soldier not only are the stakes
ridiculously high but they're also
intensely personal the only person
keeping cap from saving the lives of
millions as Bucky Barnes caps longtime
best friend Bucky
it's absolutely heartbreaking to watch
Bucky attack cap knifing him and
smashing his body to a pulp as the
latter desperately tries to deactivate
the Helicarrier and save innocent lives
there are more action-packed scenes in
the MCU but none as intensely personal
and character driven as this one
you're gonna be your whole life Ultron
crashes the party while this battle from
age of Ultron is nowhere close to being
the most bombastic fight scene in the
MCU it's great for a whole different
reason without a doubt it's the coolest
entrance of a villain in the MC use
history to date Ultron says some
harrowing words before sticking a bunch
of hijacked iron Legion troops on the
Avengers in their own meeting room peace
in our time
from they are caught with their pants
down all the Avengers scramble to defend
themselves instead of Iron Man just
pointing his hand at things or Hulk
smashing the Avengers actually need to
display some slick moves and dodge
attacks with acrobatic finesse the
incident you'd be hard-pressed to find a
soul alive that wouldn't qualify the
Battle of New York aka the incident as
one of the marvel cinematic universes
greatest fights from top to bottom this
enormous battle from the Avengers is an
absolute behemoth it's nearly 40 minutes
of Iron Man Captain America Hulk Thor
Black Widow and Hawkeye smashing the
ever living crap out of the Chitauri
warriors in increasingly impressive ways
before you know it Ironman is bouncing
his repulsor beams off caps shield to
wipe out entire conga lines of bad guys
in a single blow
Hulk is guarding Thor while he summons
lightning bolts directly into massive
alien slugs spines Hawkeye uses
otherworldly archery skills while black
widow pilots a flying hover bike it's a
legendary scene from start to finish the
actual greatest fight in the MCU as
great as the Avengers Throwdown in New
York was let's not pretend its glory
came from heroes like Iron Man Captain
America or Black Widow these characters
were all fine
sure and we paid them their due above
simply because it would have been rude
to do otherwise before we arrived at the
real champions these two mystery
contenders and their absolutely glorious
brawl have and will reign supreme over
all other MCU fight scenes today
yesterday and tomorrow and it's highly
unlikely the Avengers infinity war will
feature anything better we present to
you it's short sweet and absolutely
brutal brutal enough to oust every other
fight on this list from their shot at
being number one fan OHS has no clue
what he's about to go up against thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all these cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]